In 2015 Antonio Guillem takes another stock
photo, just like he has thousands of times
before.
Two years later several people use this image
to make jokes, but it’s soon lost in the
sea of internet memes.
Then, on August 19th, twitter user n1m161
makes this meme, joking about young people’s
affinity for socialism.
The post goes a little twitter viral, getting
a few thousand retweets, and suddenly, the
collective hive-mind of the internet has decided
that it’s found it’s new favorite meme.
For now.
Why do some memes capture our attention?
What causes a meme’s meteoric rise to the
top of internet culture at a given moment?
I’ve got a few ideas.
Thank you to Squarespace for sponsoring this
video.
Memes have been growing in notoriety in recent
years, I’ve noticed people, even those who
aren’t deep into internet culture talk about
“a meme they saw”.
When most people use the word meme today they’re
referring to an image macro.
These internet memes usually have two parts.
An image that serves as a caricature or symbolic
representation, and a recognizable formatting
of text, used to make a joke in conjunction
with the image.
But to understand a successful internet meme
we’ll need to dig a little into where the
word “meme” comes from.
This is Richard Dawkins, who coined the term
meme in his 1976 book “The Selfish Gene”:
Though he coined the term before internet
memes existed, the name fits, because Dawkins’
idea of meme is an almost perfect description
of how an internet meme works.
There’s a cultural “survival of the fittest”
process that helps create and spread successful
memes.
The
process selects for the appeal of the meme,
and the ability of the image and joke format
to be re-applied to many topics.
Memes are chosen by a sub culture, or by a
larger group, because they resonate.
But what causes the resonance?
Let’s use the recently popular “Distracted
Boyfriend” meme as our guiding example.
A successful meme expresses a certain idea
or concept more quickly than that idea could
be articulated.
If you look at the page for this stock photo
on Shutterstock you’ll see the full title
of “Disloyal man walking with his girlfriend
and looking amazed at another seductive girl.”
It takes a lot of words to describe this scenario,
but when you look at this image you know immediately
what’s going on.
The characters have a past, there’s a future
fallout from this moment.
But more importantly there is a core feeling
that is time consuming to lay out in words,
but that is immediately evident when viewing
the photo.
In this way it behaves as an archetypal image.
An Archetype is a deeply felt, instinctual
pre-idea form embedded in the collective unconscious.
And while the archetype itself cannot be defined
or expressed explicitly, we can recognize
it when it’s represented within an archetypal
image.
The archetype embedded in this image is a
complex scenario, recognized by all of us
easily, it can be described by the phrase
“the grass is always greener on the other
side of the fence.”
But even using that phrase is resorting to
use of symbolism to represent this scenario.
A good meme succeeds because it taps into
the past experiences of the collective and
as it spreads becomes a part of the collective
symbolism for those experiences.
That’s Stefan Hayden, a Shutterstock developer
I spoke with who’s working on an image editing
tool that lets people quickly create their
own versions of the meme.
This is why stock images tend to make great
memes.
Images that end up being used in successful
memes often have characters whose expressions
are exaggerated.
They appear as caricatures for the emotion
or feeling they are expressing.
Those exaggerated elements make the meme stronger,
it’s symbolism is more easily detected by
more people.
And the exaggerated effect is funny, we like
it for the same reason we like cartoons.
This isn’t to suggest that a meme has to
be gotten by everyone.
A meme can appeal to small group.
Sometimes they have appeal because only a
small group recognized the symbolism of a
meme.
Memes often act as a sort of “in group”
identifier, like inside jokes, and tv show
references, a meme is a way of discovering
who we have a common base of understanding
with.
And their short but intense lifespans make
them signposts for eras of internet culture.
The perfect meme often seems to be one where
the image element is broad enough that many
people “get” the symbolism, while the
joke conveyed through text has a very narrow
appeal.
Let’s examine the modes in which a meme
can interact with culture.
Initial exposure.
The first mode is how the meme interacts with
the viewer upon the first exposure.
With the “Distracted Boyfriend” meme,
the first time you see it you find it funny
because of the way someone modified it to
make a joke, but also because the photo itself
is funny.
Some memes are never replicate, and operate
only in this mode.
Continued application.
In the second mode a meme’s ability to be
remixed is crucial.
This is the mode where the meme gains the
most traction.
A good meme has a formula that makes the application
of the core archetype to a many different
scenarios easy.
In this mode most of the humor is generated
from seeing all the ways in which people can
use the meme.
Subversion of the formula.
In the third mode, humor and freshness are
generated by the subversion of the established
formula of the meme.
Now that most of the possible applications
are exhausted, people begin to modify the
original nature of the meme and use it to
express ideas that are similar, or even the
inverse of the original archetype.
Acceptance into cultural lexicon.
Ultimately a meme can enter the cultural lexicon.
It can become a tool or a short of shorthand
that we might use to refer to the archetype
at the core of the meme.
Most memes won’t operate within all these
modes.
But successful memes that stick around usually
operate well in multiple modes.
Types of memes existed before the internet.
But the internet has had a big influence on
memes
First, by increasing the number of connections
and points of communication, it speeds up
the evolution of memes.
Second, the internet it makes this evolutionary
process much more visible than it’s been
in the past.
Before the internet tracking little know non-image
memes out in culture was extremely difficult.
Although for the most part, memes remain enigmatic,
and difficult to track.
But maybe it’s worth the effort.
I think we underestimate the importance of
what meme represent.
The individual meme might seem trivial, but
tracking trends across many memes reveal the
deeply felt ideas in internet culture that
they represent.
We can learn something about ourselves by
tracking which memes survive.
At the very least, become an evolutionary
force that helps shape our culture, and share
a meme.
Make your next move with Squarespace.
Squarespace is a one stop shop to grab a unique
domain and build a beautiful website for whatever
project or idea you have.
Building and running a website doesn’t have
to be a pain, with squarespace’s all-in-one
platform and 24/7 support you can stop fiddling
with annoying code, and other details, and
focus on bringing your ideas to life.
Although if you do want to get under the hood
and customize things, you can do that to,
Squarespace gives you some awesome template
as a starting place, but the flexible platform
lets you customize it to fit whatever needs
you have.
Start your free trial today, at Squarespace.com
and enter offer code THOMASFLIGHT to
get 10% off your first purchase.